My name is Mahesh Mehta. People also
kiss and touch the Kaaba Sharif. Later, there is the Black Stone.
People also kiss the Black Stone because
God sent Adam al-Salam
from heaven and fixed him there. So is it
permissible or not, brother. Mahesh Bhai,
MashaAllah, since the time IRF was established in 1991,
MashaAllah, we have been coming to the IRF. And
if
any person who watched the maximum number of cassettes
in those few years when our video library was started, Mahesh Bhai,
MashaAllah, what you were saying that
people kiss the Black Stone, of course I know they kiss, then is
it correct? People have a misconception that
Muslims worship the Black Stone. No
Muslim worships the Black Stone. People have a
misconception that people worship the Kaaba
because we go to Mecca, do
tawaf in Umrah, Hajj, pray and turn towards it.
So why is this? The reason for this is that the
Kaaba, Hajj and Awad is the Qibla for us.  In
direction if we have to pray today
some will say facing east some will say
west some will say north some will say
south some east some west which way should we look when saint
Mirza
Fars first drew the world map the
south pole was at the top the north pole was at the bottom and the
Kaaba was in the middle western cartography the
Kaaba is in the middle the
center so for us the Kaaba is the qibla
direction when we go for umrah or hajj we go around the Kaaba for hajj we go around the Kaaba we do tawaf
we do not do tawaf
because we worship him we do tawaf
because it is the message of Allah it is the
work of Allah it is the work of our Rasool
but if I think logically then I can
think that every circle has a center a mere
centre because we believe
that Allah is one God that is why we do
tawaf around the Kaaba to show
that Allah
is one God and what you
said that Muslims kiss is absolutely correct
I even kiss my son.
Tomorrow you will say that I worship my son. I will
reply to that. There
is a hadith of Sahih Bukhari, point number two Hazrat Umar (RA)
who was the second caliph of Islam,
looking at Hajj Awad, says that this black stone can
neither do anything good for me nor can it do
anything bad for me because
my last messenger Mohammad Salam kissed it, that is why
I am kissing it. It can neither benefit me nor cause
me any harm. It can neither harm me nor can it
benefit me because Mohammad
Salam kissed it, that is why I am kissing it. These
words of the second caliph Hazrat Umar (RA) are
enough to tell that we Muslims do
not worship Hajj Awad and during the
time of Mohammad Salam, many
companions used to give azaan by climbing the Kaaba. If
any Muslim worships Kaaba or Hajj Awad,
any idol worshipper who worships an idol will
never climb beyond that, then to say
that we do not worship Kaaba or Hajj Awad  Many companions, while worshipping the Sunnah,
climbed the Kaaba and gave the Azaan, so this
proves that we do not worship the Kaaba or the Sunnah;
we only consider it as the Qibla,
and because the Messenger of Allah kissed the Ilam,
we do not worship him.
Regarding women, in mic number three, if
any non-Muslim woman wants to ask a question, she can do so.
My name is Vijay Laxmi, I am
working with the shipping company, I am a fleet
personal
executive, and about two months ago, I just felt like I should read the
Quran. I should know more
about Islam, and so I just felt like asking
one of my friends, who was there
in the train, who I did not know what the
Quran is, so she told me, okay, fine, this is what it is, I read about it,
and
I really loved reading it, and then once upon a time,
I read all about Muhammad (peace be upon him)
and the Sunnah and all the ways of life and
Everything and I found it to be so
beautiful like it to me how to live you know which
life I never led before it was like so
beautiful and I could not explain I can not explain now to like how I
feel coming into
Islam and knowing about
Allah and like I have today I have
surrendered myself to the laws of Islam and
Mohammad but I can not but
the problem is that I can not tell my
parents no my relatives no my brother like
what is Allah I want to tell them what
is Allah like you just ask one thing like
today I ask just I wanted to be here
I wanted to be over here and listen
to your statement and I just thought oh I could be there
with you and to listen to your ban and see today
evening all alone I am over here to
listen to you the faith you know the confidence the faith
and what ever ask like no I want this
and I do get  But that faith, that love, that affection, I have not ever seen
in all these
years in my life, but now I feel that it's like I can't
explain in which
world I have come to in to now, but the same way I want to
explain to my parents
what Islam is, but they are not ready to
accept what it is, how am I suppose
to make them explain who is Allah, what
is Allah, sister, very good question, Ben has asked
that she wanted, will the answer be
in Urdu, is it fine, can you understand
Urdu, Hindi, or do you want me to reply in
English, no, no, I can understand Hindi
and Urdu as well, but you are like me, my
English is more powerful than my Urdu,
Hindi, Ben has asked that she wanted to
read the Quran Majeed, and a few months ago, two-
three months ago, she asked a Muslim friend,
and she read the Quran Majeed, and
after reading the Quran Majeed, she started feeling so much peace,
and to Muhammad S  After knowing this, today she
says that I have surrendered to the will of
Allah and teachings
Salam.
She has happily surrendered herself to follow the teachings of Allah and the
message of Muhammad Salam
and has surrendered Alhamdulillah, which
a true Muslim does. She says that I have
so much peace in my heart but how should I tell this to
my parents, how should I
tell this to my father, how should I tell my mother,
how should I tell my brother and they will not accept this, in
what way should I tell them about Allah Subhana Taala,
sister, today my speech was that Muhammad
Sallallahu Wasallam is mentioned
in different religious books, so whatever you
heard here today, go and tell that to your mother and your
brother
that I heard the speech, there was a person who
calls himself Zakir,
he says that Muhammad Sallallahu Wasallam is
also in the book of Hindu religion and
according to Hindu religious books, he is the last prophet
and the one whom people call Muhammad Sallam is not a true person
because I know that non-Muslims
Muslims have a misunderstanding about Mohammad Salam
and whatever I have said in this speech,
whatever you can remember, you should
tell that to your parents and your brother as far as
Allah is concerned, in
what way should I tell my parents about Allah,
next Saturday as I said on the
22nd, my speech is about the image of God
in different religions, concept of God in
various world religions and in this, Insha
Allah, the way in which I have proved today that
Mohammad Sallallahu is the last prophet
from different religious books, on that day
after a week, Insha Allah, I will prove
that it is necessary in every religion that there is only one
God, there is only one Allah
and this God has no idol, no
idol and we should worship only him, so
after listening to both these speeches,
both the main pillars, the
main pillars of Islam, which is also the Kalma that believe that there
is one God and no one should be worshipped except him
and Mohammad  Sallallahu
Wasallam is his last prophet and servant. It
is necessary for a person to believe this. To
become a Muslim, I want to say that
whenever you talk to your family members, then talk about this state. Do not talk about
false things. Do not
say that this is wrong
in this religious book, this is wrong in Hinduism. Do not do this.
Allah Ta'ala says in chapter three of Imran,
verse number 64,
so let us come to the matter of you and me.
First of all,
Allah, we worship only one Allah Subhan Ta'ala.
But when you accept Islam
and start practicing Islam, you have to make
your family members realize that
you are a better person. What you were before is a
different person and what you are today is a
different person. You should love your mother more.
Muhammad (PBUH) says that
Paradise is under the feet of the mother. There is a
sahih hadith of Musad Ahmad. So you have to make them realize
that you love your mother more and
you love your father more.  If you
loved someone, you did not
believe in them earlier, today start believing in only those
things which are against the Quran and Hadith,
against the commandments of Allah and the message of Muhammad Sallam, leave those things and
believe in everything, then they will realize that you
love them more and slowly and
lovingly do the Yakh Saniyamrajya, it may take
some days, some
weeks, some years, it may take some time, it is your duty to do Zikr, just like it is
my duty to do Zikr,
Allah Subhan Taala gives guidance,
Allah gives guidance, we only do Zikr, in the
same way you invite your
family members and later leave it to Allah,
hope the answer question